The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this
is a 2-3 tree.
So as you can see, every node
has-- so the 2-3 is either
two children or three children.
Every node can have either
one key or two keys.
And the correlation
is that every--
so if there are n keys in a
node, it has n plus 1 children.
So the way that works is
similar to binary search trees.
So if you have value here, the
two children surrounding it--
so this side is less,
this side is more.
So it's essentially sort of
going in order reversal, left
child, root, right child.
So [INAUDIBLE], it's ordered.
So generally a B tree
will have some nodes.
So let's say n and
n plus 1 children.
And if you take
anything in the middle,
look at the two children,
all the keys in this sub-tree
are smaller than the key
here, and all the keys
in this sub-tree are
larger than the key here.
So that's the general node.
So before we go
into more details
of the properties
and everything,
the question is why use B-trees.
So if we do a quick
depth analysis,
we can see that the
depth is to log n rate.
Is that clear to everyone sort
of, why the depth is log n?
Because you have branching just
like in binary search trees.
In fact, you have
more branching.
But in any case,
depth is to log n.
But why use B-trees over
binary search trees?
Anyone have a
reason why you would
prefer to use B-trees or not?
So all the operations
are still log n.
Any guesses?
None.
OK.
Well, OK, the reason
is memory hierarchy.
So normally in
[INAUDIBLE], we just
assume that the computer
has access to memory,
and you can just pick up things
from disk and constant time
and do your operations with
it, and you don't worry
about caches and everything.
But that's not how
computers work.
So in a computer, you
have-- so those of you
who have taken some
computer architecture
class [INAUDIBLE] or something,
you will know that hierarchy.
So there's a CPU-- so
let's draw it somewhere.
So you have your CPU.
And [INAUDIBLE] CPU,
you have some registers.
You have your caches,
L1, L2, L3, whatever.
You have your RAM.
You have disk after that.
So disk [? loads. ?] Then
you have your, I don't know,
your cloud, whatever.
So each level, your
memory size grows
and your access
time grows as well.
So in the basic memory
hierarchy model,
we have just two levels
of hierarchy, let's say.
So you have cache connected
by a high bandwidth channel
to the CPU, and you have a
low bandwidth channel to disk.
So the difference
is-- so essentially
you can consider that cache
just has infinite speed.
Cache, just like,
whatever you can take it.
You don't have any cost for
bringing in stuff from cache.
But it's finite size.
So the way cache works is it
has a bunch of words, which
is a finite number of words.
So each word has size B, and
let's say you have m words.
However, hard disk is just,
let's say, infinite memory,
but it has some cost
associated to accessing things.
Also when you access
things from hard disk,
you copy them into cache.
When you copy a block of
size b, you take it up
from the hard disk,
and you take a block,
and you put it into cache.
And you have to get rid of
something because it's fine.
So what you want to do
is you want to utilize
that b block efficiently.
You just want to bring
a b block every time
you want to access a new node.
In a binary search tree,
normal operations are what?
You start in the root
and go to a node.
But that's not very easily
correlated with this.
Right?
So if you want to
utilize an entire block,
you would want something like
a block which sort of goes down
the tree.
But that's not how
binary trees are stored.
Binary trees are
stored this way.
So that's the nice
thing about B-trees.
So this is just a 2-3 tree.
This is not a general B-tree.
A general B-tree will
have a bunch of nodes,
and we'll come to that number.
But generally you want to make
that number of nodes something
like the cache-- what is it?
The word size in the cache.
So once you do that, you can
get an entire node from disk,
like work on that, and then
get another [INAUDIBLE],
so your height is reduced.
And you can do your
operation much quicker,
because you're not accessing
disk every time you're
going down a level.
Sorry.
You are accessing disk every
time you go down a level,
but you're utilizing
the whole block
when you're accessing disk.
Good?
Sort of make sense?
OK.
So let's write down the
specifications for B-trees now.
All right.
So number of children.
So first of all, a
B-tree has something
called a branching factor.
So in the 2-3 tree, the
branching factor is two.
So what that means is
simply that it just balances
the number of children.
So the number of children has to
be greater than or equal to 2.
Other than the root node.
The root node can have
less than B children.
It's fine.
Also it's upper bounded
by 2B [? plus ?] 2B.
Notice that this is
a strict upper bound.
So you can have at most 2B
minus 1 children from a node.
Also remember that the number
of keys, the number of keys
is just 1 less than
the number of children.
Therefore, these inequalities
are just reduced by 1.
So you have minus 1 and
you have 2B minus 1.
So the number of keys can be
between minus 1 and 2B minus 2.
The rationale for that
will become clear-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is B the
height of the tree?
PROFESSOR: No, B
is the branching.
B is the branching factor.
So that is the
number of children.
It's not the number of children.
It's a bound of the
number of children.
So like in the 2-3
tree, B is equal to 2,
and this is a 2-3 tree.
So the 2 refers to-- you
can have either two children
or you can have three children.
And so the upper bound on
children is 2B minus 1.
2B minus 1 is equal to 3.
So you can have two
or three children.
And correspondingly, you
can have either one or two
keys in a node.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
OK So coming back to this.
So the root does not
have a lower bound.
The root can have one
child in any tree.
So you have a B equal
to 5 tree, the root
can still have
one child-- sorry.
Not one child, one key
element, two children.
All right.
It's good.
Also it's completely balanced.
So all the leaves
are the same depth.
So you can see it here, right?
So you can't have a
dangling node here.
This is not allowed.
You have to have a leaf.
You have to have
something going down,
and everything ends
at the same level.
All right.
So that's the thing.
So also the leaves obviously
don't have children,
so this condition is
violated by the leaf.
So that's the basic
structure of a B-tree.
So the first operation
we'll consider on B-trees
is searching.
So that should be
relatively straightforward.
So remember how searching is
done in the binary search tree.
You bring in a value
x compared to the key.
Let's say x is less than
K, you go down this path.
Let's say x is greater than
So similarly in a B-tree.
So let's say we
bring in a value.
Let's say you are
looking for 20.
So you bring in 20
compared to this.
20 is less than 30,
so you go down here.
Now you have two values.
So where does 20 fit in here?
Not here.
It fits here.
OK.
Go down this tree.
You find 20, that's it.
So in general, you bring in a
key K, you look at this node,
and you go through
all the values.
So something I forgot to
mention, which should be clear.
All the keys in a node, they're
sorted, one after the other.
So your values go like this.
So they're increasing
in this way.
Make sense?
So you bring in a key.
Look at all the keys in
the node you're looking at,
pick the place where K fits
in, unless it's already
in the node.
Then you're done.
You've found it.
Otherwise, let's say K fits
in between these two guys.
So you go down this
child and continue.
So searching with log
n, similar to BSTs.
So searching is not
very interesting.
So next is insertion.
So insertion is a little more
interesting than searching.
So what you do in
insertion is you--
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PROFESSOR: So before we resume,
does anyone have any questions
about the structure of B-trees.
We rushed through
that quite fast.
About how B-trees
are structured,
everyone good with that?
OK, also any questions about
searching in a B-tree or a BST?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Just a
random question.
So the 38 there, it can
only have two children.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So one value, two children.
So you have some
node in the B-tree,
and whatever is
below it is split
into parts by the elements.
So if you have n
elements, it splits it up
into n plus 1 segments.
AUDIENCE: You said that the root
didn't have to follow the root.
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: Why is that?
PROFESSOR: Well, you'll see when
we do insertion and deletion
why that's necessary.
But essentially you can
consider that it's an invariant.
And all we have to do is
preserve that invariant.
So the root, it has to
still have less than two--
it still has to have
the upper bound.
But it doesn't need
to have a lower bound.
AUDIENCE: How do you choose B?
PROFESSOR: Well, the whole
[INAUDIBLE] cache size,
so something with that.
So you probably want 2B to
be about your cache size
so you can get the
whole block in one go.
I've never implemented
a B-tree, so I
don't know how it's
actually done in practice.
But that is the reason, so
I'm assuming it's something
to do with the cache length.
AUDIENCE: Is the 14, is it
a child of both 10 and 17?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's
not a child of either.
It's a child of this node.
So this node has two
elements, so it's
being divided-- dividing the
interval up into three parts.
So it's in between 10
and 17 is the point here.
AUDIENCE: So then this
node has five children?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
No, it has three children.
So don't think of
every key as a node.
Think of the whole
unit as a node.
So it's not necessarily--
in a binary search tree,
you have one element,
but here every node
has multiple elements.
That's the point of it.
Anyone else?
OK, let's start with searching.
So let's leave this here.
Well, you have the formulas
up there, so that's good.
Insertion.
Let's start with insertion.
We already did searching.
So insertion is you
bring in a new key K,
and you want to insert
it into the tree.
So what's the problem
that could happen?
You can find the location where
you want to insert it, just
like searching.
You just go down the tree and
find where it should be placed.
But once you do place
it, you have a problem.
What is the problem?
The problem is that one of your
nodes will become overfull.
Whatever.
It'll overflow, and
that's not what you want.
So you want some way
so you can manage this.
How do you manage this?
So I have this lovely prop here,
which I hope to demonstrate.
OK.
So here we have B equal to 4.
So let's first figure
out the number of keys.
So what is the minimum number of
keys, anyone for B equal to 4?
AUDIENCE: Three.
PROFESSOR: Three, precisely.
So what is the maximum
number of keys?
AUDIENCE: Six.
PROFESSOR: 4 into
2 minus 3, yeah.
Correct.
3, 4.
It's not seven, there's
a strictly less than sign
somewhere.
Yes.
And you'll see why it's
not seven in a minute.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh.
Hypocritical of me.
All right.
So as you can see,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
So some insertion happened.
Is the writing clear?
Can everyone read the numbers?
49 looks a little skewed.
Anyway, essentially
these are all sorted.
This is the parent node.
Doesn't matter what's over here.
All that matters is 8, 56,
and whatever's in between.
So what we do when we
have an overfull node
is something that's
called a split operation.
So split.
And there's something
which is called
a merge, which we'll
come to later when
we're doing deletion.
But a split is--
very intuitively,
it splits the node
into two parts.
So what it does is when
you have an overfull node--
so the number of
elements here is what?
2B minus 1, which is
just 1 over the max.
So what do you do is you
take the middle element
and remove it.
and now you split the
node into two parts.
Observe that there are
three here and three here,
which is perfect.
And now what you do
with the middle node--
so now you're
actually disrupting
the structure of the
tree, because there
was one pointer going in.
There was one child.
And now you have two children.
So somehow you need to
adjust the parent node,
because the parent node
had only one child.
Well, at least there are other
children off to the side.
But here it had only one child,
and now it's split apart.
So you do something very simple.
You just insert
this guy in here.
And then you say,
oh, this points here,
and this points here.
Make sense?
I'm going to get
rid of these two.
And you can even
convince yourself
that this preserves all
the nice properties.
So your children have
nicely fallen back
into their interval.
Your sequence is
completely correct,
because this was the
middle element of this.
So this divides this
interval properly.
This is also between 8 and 56,
because this was in this node.
So all the properties.
But there's one property
that is a problem.
So you have just increased the
size of the parent node by 1.
So now it's possible that the
parent node has overflowed.
So what do you do?
You split it again.
And split it again.
And if at any
point, you're fine,
you look at the parent node
and go, OK, that's fine.
That's in the range.
But every time it overflows,
you can keep going.
And how many times
can you do this?
You can do this all
the way up to the root.
And when you reach the
root, either it's fine
or the root is too big.
It's reached 2B minus 1.
And then you split
the root, and you
get one single
[INAUDIBLE] up there.
So that, in answer
to your question,
that is why you need that
property in some sense.
Not a very convincing
argument, but sort of.
So let's actually
do an insertion
in this tree we have here.
So we are going to insert 16.
So 16 comes in here.
It's less than 30,
it goes to the left.
It's between 10 and 17,
it goes in the middle.
16.
And it's greater than
14, so we add 16 here.
All right.
That seems good.
All the properties fine.
This still has two elements,
which is the maximum,
but it's good.
It doesn't overflow.
Let's insert something else.
Let's insert 2.
So 2 goes to 30,
goes down, goes down.
And we have a problem, because
2 has overflowed this node.
So we split.
And the way we split is we
take the middle element.
So we split the node here.
And 3 goes up to the
parent, so 3 goes here.
And all good, except for
the parent has overflowed.
So what do we do
with the parent?
We split the parent again.
And this time, it's right down
the middle, the 10 goes up.
So OK, let's get rid of this.
So now that we split the
parent, the 10 goes up here.
And you're good.
It's a bit cluttered, so
let me reposition the 17.
Did those two
operations make sense?
Questions?
AUDIENCE: If your node size
[INAUDIBLE] number of--
PROFESSOR: So just pick
the-- first of all-- OK.
If the way we're doing it--
when your node is overflowing,
it's returning only one
thing at a time, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So if your
node is overflowing,
it'll be 2t minus 1, which
is an odd number always.
There might be a case where
you get an even number
if you do something weird.
Maybe you have a-- there are
different ways to do B-trees.
But if it does, you can probably
pick the one, either of them,
and then [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not sure about that.
I'll look into it.
But in general, if you're doing
it this way, it's always odd.
So you don't have
to worry about that.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: If we did reach
all the way to the root
and then went one more up--
PROFESSOR: So what
you would do is--
AUDIENCE: That root would have--
PROFESSOR: That root would
have two children, one element
and two children, which is
fine because we didn't put
that restriction on the root.
That's good.
How we doing on time?
OK, we have some time.
Let's jump into deletion, unless
anyone else has questions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] any point?
PROFESSOR: So-- oh, yeah.
That's a good-- thank you.
So you are going
down to the leaves
at most-- at most
of the leaf ones,
and you're going back up one.
So it's like log n plus
log n, and you're good.
Let's do deletion.
So deletion is more complicated.
So the reason, it'll be clear.
So the problem in deletion
will be remove a node
and a node is now underfull.
So it has less than B minus
1 keys in it suddenly.
So let's turn this around.
So again B equal to 4.
This node is a problem.
Only two things in it.
So what do we do?
So before we go into that,
let's make this assumption
that-- there are two
steps to deletion.
The first step is making
the deletion at a leaf.
How do you do that?
So the way you make a deletion
at a leaf is, let's say,
you have a key.
You come down in your
B-tree, and you add a node.
Oh, this key needs
to be deleted.
But it's not a leaf.
So what do you do?
So essentially what you do is
you look at these two subtrees.
So it might have
only one subtree.
If it's at the end,
it will have only one.
Actually, no, that's not true.
Ignore that.
If it's not a leaf,
it has two subtrees.
So either take the
rightmost element
in this subtree,
which is a leaf,
because you can always
keep going down,
right, right, right, right
till you get to a leaf,
or the leftmost element
in this subtree.
So that is just the next
element after this guy.
So you delete this, and
you bring this up to here.
We'll do an example of
this, and it'll be clearer.
So you take either the rightmost
element in the left subtree
or the leftmost element
in the right subtree
and bring it up here.
So you sort of like move
the deletion to the leaf.
And now it's easier
to deal with.
So we will come to that.
Also just note that this is not
what is done in the recitation.
This algorithm for
deletion, I think,
is not done in the
recitation notes.
This is a different thing, which
I'll send out a link for later.
But I believe it
works, because I got it
from the [INAUDIBLE] reference.
So once you move to the leaf--
so now let's look at this.
So this is a node
that is underfull.
And you want to fix it.
So how do you fix it?
So what do is you
look at its siblings.
So in this case,
it has one sibling.
It can have up to two siblings.
It can have left or right.
So what you do is you
look at a sibling.
And this sibling is
actually 1 over the minimum.
And if it's 1 over the
minimum, then it's really easy.
All you have to do is take
the leftmost thing here--
or if it's the
sibling on this side,
take the rightmost thing here.
And look at its parent.
So you bring the parent down,
and you move the sibling up.
And there we go.
So you basically are rotating
the thing into place.
So you move the parent down
into the underfull node,
and you replace the parent
by the leftmost thing here.
Everyone see why that
preserves everything?
And the child is also shifted.
Make sure you see that.
So the child which was in this
subtree is now in this subtree.
But then you can
have the situation
where you don't
have a nice sibling
to take care of your problems.
So in this scenario, the
sibling is barely full.
It has three things, and it
can't donate anything to you.
So what do you do in that case?
So then you do something which
is a parallel of the split
operation.
You do a merge.
So what do you have?
So here you have B minus 2,
and here you have B minus 1.
And you get 2B minus 3.
Well, you've got
another element.
You also take the parent.
So how do you do the merge.
I just want to show
you the merge first.
So the way you do it is
you move the parent down,
and you merge these two.
Seems OK?
So you move the parent node
down and merge these two.
And, well, now this
comes together,
and this points
into the new node.
Sort of clear what's going on?
Questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So now the
parent is underfull?
PROFESSOR: Well, so you
have-- yeah, exactly.
So you have decreased
the size of the parent,
so it might be underfull.
So you propagate.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: So are these
all different techniques
for doing that?
PROFESSOR: So there
are two cases.
So either you have a sibling
which has extra nodes to donate
to you or you don't.
If you don't, then
you have to do this.
AUDIENCE: But what
about that case?
Or is that just like--
PROFESSOR: No, that is
moving it down to the leaf.
Once you move the
deletion down to the leaf,
so here we have something now.
And now you move it
all the way back up.
So there are two cases.
Let's do an example.
That'll make it clearer.
How are we doing on time?
Five minutes, all right.
So we are going to delete 38.
38 is gone.
But we want to move
it down to the leaf.
So let's take an element.
Let's say we take 41.
So we take 41 and
move it up here.
41 is the leftmost thing
in the right subtree.
So this vacancy doesn't
really affect anything,
because this node still has
the right number of things,
because it's still got one
thing in it, which is good.
So you're fine.
This is now just 48.
Let's say we now delete 41.
So 41 is gone.
So now that 41 is
gone, what do you
replace this blank spot with?
Either this or this, right?
Doesn't matter.
So let's just do this
one for consistency.
So you have 48 here.
And now you a problem
because you have a blank box.
So can you rotate?
Yes, no?
No, right?
Because sibling is barely full.
So what can you do?
So you merge.
And how do you merge?
You move the 48 down, and
you combine everything.
So this is kind of
hard to understand,
but this is like a
zero-element node.
So when you merge, you
have 32, 48, and nothing,
so it's just 32 and 48.
So what you do is--
so this seems weird,
but this is just
another empty node.
You just propagated
the emptiness upwards.
Now you take this empty node,
and you look for its siblings.
Again, its sibling is--
well, it's barely full.
So what do you do now?
You bring the 30 down,
and you merge this.
So let's do that.
30 comes down, and there we go.
Looks fine?
Does that tree look good?
Questions about the operation?
I'm sure it was not
clear, but-- anything?
Make sense?
OK, let's do a deletion where
we can actually do a rotation.
So let's go ahead and delete 20.
So you do your searching,
go down the tree.
You find the 20 under here.
So now, OK.
So you're left with just--
actually never mind.
We'll do another one.
So this doesn't do anything.
You lost the 20, and you're
left with the 24 this time.
So now you delete the 24.
So now that you've
got rid of the 24,
you have a blank box here now.
But its sibling is
not barely full.
It has something to donate.
So anyone, which elements
are going to rotate?
AUDIENCE: 17 and 16.
PROFESSOR: 16 and 17, right.
Cool.
So 16 goes up, 17 goes down.
And you're done.
You're consistent again.
So that was deletion.
Those are the two
cases for deletion.
Does that make sense?
Anyone?
Any questions?
OK.
So that's all the topics we
were supposed to cover today.
Any questions about
any of the operations,
any of the other topics,
lecture, anything?